the smell of death is everywhere
almost all is like an open-air symmetry
nearly a year of the Lobato between the
so-called Islamic state and Iraqi troops
ended corpses still fill the streets we
meet surah al Husseini the young nurse
has volunteered to help remove the
bodies in this old house in this room we
found a hundred and fifty corpses they
were all shot in the head yes
the stench is hard to take it fills your
nostrils we took away all the bodies
then we burned the room and to sanitize
it how did they all fit men then women
and children
they are still bones here we stuck to
the blankets anyone passing by can see
the corpses under the rubble heads
without bodies a girl's hair still stuck
to her Abhaya the volunteers have
removed 1350 bodies so far the old city
in Mosul was an is stronghold sometimes
they also find dead fighters - chicken
masala Isis was responsible for your
sister's death correct and today you are
removing the bodies of some of their
fighters what goes through your mind
when you do this this is their place
this is where they deserved I lost my
sister but Tina's our grave I can visit
her
the fighters remains are there without a
grave the fact that I get to remove
their bodies is my biggest revenge
fighting them with a weapon is exactly
what they want they want us to be
inhumane they want us to fight each
other it's life-threatening work for the
volunteers there could be unexploded
bombs anywhere live why don't you wait
till the area's secured and then remove
the bodies well not security officials
many times nobody wants to do this and
no one wants to come here families can't
identify their loved ones because of a
lack of forensic medicine people hunting
for their relatives I've seen women
older men they come looking for their
dead children they say their children
died here but they're not sure if this
is the exact place because everything's
been obliterated what shocks you about
all of this the bodies of women and
children but what bothers me even more
is that no one asks about them not even
the government 3,000 people remain
missing their bodies likely somewhere
here beneath the rubble